now it's time for tonight's hashtagwars
please welcome this week's sponsor that
I am legally bound to introduce right
now mr. Donald Trump
I remember I want to Joycelyn nice night
early stop it it's not your birthday
this is art let someone else have a
moment let someone else have a moment I
have every moment I buy all the mama all
right fine
this is our second to last night with
Donald Trump we wanted next week it'll
all be over we wanted a chance to
discuss the truly important issues with
him as he is running for president of
the United States that's why tonight's
hashtag is how I will fix everything all
right it's very educational examples
might include increasing funding for
Zika and other dangerous diseases or
deal with North Korea's burgeoning
nuclear unbelievable hold it I'm sorry
chip hold it right I was at the hashtag
listen to me chip Sajak I'll fix America
right now by changing that stupid head
it's a very thought-provoking hat no
it's not I want to prove that I can do
Internet puns better than anybody
especially your panel of aging baristas
here so tonight's hashtag is something
truly dumb hashtag fish TV fish team we
can't do that's ridiculous you're like
Oh an extra-large baby in a tie I would
hate myself then cuz I hate babies I
grind them up and then snort them
alright that's enough that's enough the
hashtag is fish TV I guess what are what
would examples of that be examples may
include golden gills or don't trust the
beach in apartment 23 isn't that funny
well the crowd loves it so I guess I
have to put 60 seconds on the clock and
begin
Johnny to catch your predator such as a
shark or a barracuda yes fun excuse me
excuse it sort of a sector kids you
don't even ever see is you'd have a
bunch of kids what blubber she wrote
alright fine
Hey Artemis see uh the fellatio with
Matt Lauer
uh Johnny the fresh fish of bel-air yes
points
Cheryl hey perf Your Enthusiasm oh good
excuse me what excuse me excuse why
didn't you just get a butter you paid
for the whole can show you couldn't buy
a buzzer I got a buzzer and a butter
chip you son of a bitch and let me tell
you how you have the butter somewhere
you don't want to know about let me tell
you i binge watch this sturgeon things
alright fine uh Cheryl dang ray Donovan
yes fine excuse me why excuse me the
People vs r oj simpson hi boys I guess
Artemis CSI Pacific Ocean yes huh
excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me
all right no one is even trying to stop
you at this point Hill Street Blues all
right fine Gil Street Blues points
Cheryl 60 minnows yes